the lion
its mane is an aphrodisiac
and its tail a weapon of war
but is the king prepared to take on
every other cat on earth
to be the king has got to be just
amazing
plus the owl
it can see with its ears
and may be able to hear if a mouse is
pregnant
but it's their wings that could
revolutionize the way all of us fly the
friendly skies
they don't make noise as they move
which is
pretty cool
[Music]
and frogs they hop they hide and they
may just be the key to human immortality
they are able to go into what is quite
literally suspended animation
[Music]
this is where savage meets science
and wild becomes
wow
this is
everything you didn't know about animals
[Music]
their ancestors are millions of years
older than dinosaurs
[Music]
they can both drink and breathe through
their skin
they're small enough to hold in your
hand but maybe use gloves
because some of them carry enough toxin
to kill 20 full-grown men
they're frogs and with over 5 000
different kinds worldwide they're one of
the most varied species on earth
they occupy environments ranging from
the arctic circle all the way down to
the equator
and
some of them are completely terrestrial
some are completely aquatic they're on
the mountains they're in valleys they
kind of do it all
from the largest the goliath frog which
can weigh as much as a newborn baby
to one of the weirdest the surinam toad
which gives birth through holes in her
back
[Music]
frogs really do run the gamut and to
prove it we're counting down seven of
the most fascinating frogs
starting with the northern leopard frog
if he looks familiar it's because you
may have taken a high school science
class together
leopard frogs were the species that most
people dissected because that was the
species that people could get easily so
that led especially the northern leopard
frog to become kind of the amphibian lab
rat so why is such a well-studied frog
on a show about things you didn't know
[Music]
because in late 2014 scientists revealed
the discovery of an entirely new species
of leopard frog a close cousin to the
northern
[Music]
most surprisingly this new frog wasn't
discovered in the jungles of costa rica
but somewhere much less exotic
[Music]
this new species of frog was found on
staten island in new york and from the
site where it was found you can see the
skyline in manhattan that doesn't happen
too often
it's only the second new species to be
found on the continental u.s in 30 years
scientists are calling it the atlantic
coast leopard frog
so even in unlikely places we're still
finding new species
[Music]
our number two most fascinating
amphibian is the wood frog because it
can do something that humans have only
dreamed of
from paris hilton to larry king and even
muhammad ali
these are just some of the people who
have dreamed of a day in which they can
cheat death by cryogenically freezing
their bodies for the future for now it
remains science fiction
that is unless you're a wood frog
probably one of the most remarkable
frog species out there is the wood frog
it's the only amphibian that lives in
the arctic environment
wood frogs are able to go into what is
quite literally suspended animation
to survive the deep chill of winter wood
frogs burrow under the leaf litter and
then let themselves freeze
these animals are literally able to shut
down their life functions for months at
a time
they pump
most of the water inside their bodies
into kind of interstitial spaces in
their body like lymph nodes and then
load their cells the interior the cells
up with glucose which can act as
antifreeze
doing this some frogs can maintain a
temperature of just under five degrees
fahrenheit
and how cold is that
not that i recommend this but if you
drops it on the ground it would shatter
into a million pieces like an ice cube
and wood frogs can stay frozen solid
like this for up to nine months
their heart doesn't beat the nerves
aren't firing nothing happens for months
and then if you warm it up gently
it kind of stretches itself out and it
can hop away
that's
astounding for any animal to be able to
do that
maybe not surprisingly nasa is kind of
interested in this because they'd like
to you know bottle us up suspend our
animation and send us to mars or
something
frog number three only looks like a
martian but really it's got nothing to
hide
it's the glass frog
this is an amphibian that literally
wears its heart on its sleeve
oh and also its liver and kidneys
but aside from telling us what the frog
had for lunch this see-through skin may
help it survive
not only is their skin translucent but
their organs can be translucent and that
species has green bones and so when
they're up in the trees one of the ways
that they're able to match their
background is by letting the background
pass through their body
so a tree snake looking up for its next
meal might only see another green leaf
frog number four doesn't have
see-through skin and probably can't help
preserve paris hilton's head
but its family did help launch the
career of one of the greatest writers of
all time
in 1865 a relatively unknown journalist
wrote a short story called the
celebrated jumping frog of calaveras
county
the story ended up being the writer's
first real success
that man was samuel clemens aka
mark twain
the subject of his story was a close
relative of the american bullfrog
[Music]
like the hopper and twain story the
american bullfrog is in the family
considered true frogs
bullfrogs are the largest frog that
lives in north america they can get to
be
over a pound or so
they're famous for
being able to jump a really really long
distance
[Music]
but how does the american bullfrog stack
up against our best human long jumpers
in 1991 mike powell of the united states
set the men's world record long jump by
leaping just over 29 feet
that's nearly five times the length of
powell's own body
pretty good but isn't bullfrog good
all frogs have been recorded jumping
over 10 times the length of their bodies
so if a bull frog was as tall as mike
powell it could jump nearly 60 feet or
one and a half school buses double
powell's record-setting jump
lucky for humans frogs are banned from
most track and field events
[Music]
like slimy little snowflakes no two
frogs are exactly alike but all frogs do
have to eat some are hungrier than
others
but frogs don't have big teeth to chew
their food into bite-sized chunks so
they have to swallow their prey whole
and that can be easier said than done
you guess the unusual way frogs get food
from their throats to their stomachs
do they a push it down with their arms
b push it down with their eyes or c
expand their stomachs into their throats
plus find out how one frog's feet can
help save lives on the highway
frogs they can flip food up to three
times their own weight right into their
mouths faster than you can blink
but swallowing prey whole isn't easy
before the break we asked if you could
guess the unusual way in which frogs get
food from their throats to their
stomachs
do they a push it down with their arms
b push it down with their eyes or c
expand their stomachs into their throats
hard as it might be to swallow the eyes
have it the answer is b
here's how it works
[Music]
a frog has nice big eyes that sit up in
that kermit kind of way
and those eyes can move up and down into
their sockets
at the bottom of each eye socket is a
thin muscle like a hammock for the
eyeball it's strong enough to keep the
eyes from falling out but flexible
enough to stretch into the mouth cavity
[Music]
if you watch frog feed they pull their
eyes down and by pushing their eyes down
that fills up their mouth cavity and
pushes the food back into their throat
so frogs put the eye
in heimlich
speaking of interesting eyes let's get
back to our list of the seven most
fascinating frauds
number five may just have the brightest
eyes of any frog on the planet but first
you have to find them
[Music]
say hello to the red eyed tree frog
with a bright green body neon orange
feet and blood red eyes this frog may
seem like a show boater
but it's actually a master of camouflage
they can kind of tuck their limbs in and
put these membranes over their eyes that
have this camouflage pattern on them
and if you put them on on the right
background
they can just completely disappear
but for all tree frogs the best strategy
for escaping death is by hanging out in
hard to reach places and whether it's
the underside of a
leaf or the clear glass of an aquarium
tree frogs do have a knack for sticking
around
the way they do it may have real world
implications for people
[Music]
it all begins with some of the most
remarkable feet in the animal kingdom
tree frogs secrete special mucus from
glands in their toe pads that can
regenerate its adhesion with each step
so if the tree frog feels itself
slipping just tapping its foot a few
times actually makes the stick stronger
[Music]
but if you tried to do that with a piece
of tape dust would quickly build up on
the surface and the tape would lose its
adhesion so why don't tree frogs have
the same problem
only recently researchers discovered
that each time the tree frog takes a
step
new mucus is secreted while the old
mucus carries away dirt and debris
through microscopic channels in the
frog's toe pads the frog's feet clean
themselves as they walk
scientists at the university of glasgow
believe these self-cleaning sticky feet
could provide a design for everything
from self-cleaning medical bandages
to no-slip tires
so soon the streets might be a little
safer thanks to a tiny little tree frog
[Music]
unlike the red-eyed tree frog
frog number six prides itself on laying
low
it's the vietnamese mossy frog
while it's actually another kind of tree
frog it spends most of its time in the
water or using its textured skin to look
like the moss it's named after
they're really good at blending into
their background where they live
but it has another defense as well and
kind of a strange one
when it's threatened it kind of rolls up
into a ball
and i think it's the only frog that's
known to do something like that
when its camo fails this frog rolls up
and plays dead like an amphibious
armadillo mixed with a mossy possum
but our final frog isn't the playing
dead kind
setting itself apart from any other
amphibian on our list some of them have
the potential to kill two full-grown
elephants with little more than a touch
these are the poison dart frogs of
central and south america
[Music]
so dart frogs get their name from a
practice of using the toxin in their
skin to
poison tips of arrows that were used by
indigenous
folks to hunt
one species the golden dart may just be
the most poisonous animal alive it's
estimated that just one gram of its
toxin could kill nearly 7 500 humans
roughly the population of gettysburg
pennsylvania
but where does the dart frog's toxin
come from in the first place
the interesting thing is that the frogs
don't manufacture the toxin they eat
ants that have the toxin in them and
they're able to then sequester it in
their skin glands
you are what you eat and this frog eats
death
so now you know from frogs that save
lives to those that kill there are no
boring frogs
[Music]
it might be able to tell if a mouse is
pregnant just by hearing it
one species in england can devour over
168 000 bats in a year
its feet are stronger than a german
shepherd's bite and his whole face is an
ear
all this and its wings may be the future
of human flight
[Music]
heads up the owl is coming
it can hear a mouse's footsteps from a
quarter mile away
its razor sharp talons can crush prey
with more force than a german shepherd
fight
they're one of the oldest modern birds
and were once so big even people had to
wash their backs
they're silent
they're deadly they're owls one of the
world's most perfect predators
they are the nighttime aerial predator i
mean they have taken over the niche of
being
the demon at night
here are just some of the numbers for
how many animals a single owl can eat in
a year
1 000 voles 200 rats 1600 lemmings 53
pounds of gopher and up to 4 000 mice
that's 38 times more meat every week
than killed by your average cat
owls really are some of the most
efficient killing machines out there
and to prove it we're breaking down all
the parts of an owl that make it so
deadly
[Music]
how does the perfect predator do it
by being the quietest bird on earth
[Music]
the primary ammo that an owl uses in
capturing their prey is stealth
and the secret to that stealth is in the
feathers on the owl's wings
[Music]
the leading edge of the wings primary
feathers are lined with little cones
that break up air turbulence flowing
over the wings into smaller quieter
currents
like turning a raging river into silent
streams
those streams are then turned into
trickles by flexible scarf-like fringes
on the trailing end of the owl's primary
and secondary feathers
lastly the entire wing is covered in a
soft carpet of fluffy tertiary feathers
that absorb sound like the foam acoustic
walls of a recording studio
so what happens is when an owl flies
instead of the air going quickly over
the wing it gets broken up and you don't
get that whooshing sound that you get
with other birds
nasa is even experimenting with the
owl's fringe-like trailing feathers to
create a similar edge on airplane wings
that can make them up to 10 times
quieter
quieter planes means airlines don't have
to worry about noise restrictions which
means they can schedule more flights and
increase their profits
of course you just know the owl will
never see a dime of that money
if you want to know how an owl hears
ignore those tufts on top of its head
those aren't ears but pretty much
everything below them is
an owl's rounded facial disc funnels and
collects sound just like cupping your
hand over your ear helps you
so really an owl's whole face is like an
ear
and it allows the owl to pick up even
the tiniest sounds from nearly 1 000
feet
that's up to three football fields away
but when food is out of sight the owl
employs its next deadly technique using
its ears to see what can't be seen
[Music]
take this mouse feeling very safe under
three feet of snow
invisible to predators
or so it thinks
[Music]
just one russell
and the predator is activated a
specialized portion of the owl's brain
instantly creates a mental map of where
the mouse is in space and maybe even
finer details
like if it's pregnant
that's right for a rodent two pink lines
could mean you're dead
barnell's preferred prey are pregnant
rodents
but how does this aerial terminator do
it
under the feathers on an owl's face
you'll see that its ears are lopsided
this gives the owl an ear up on the rest
of us
owl's ears are offset
so essentially owls can hear in 3d
they're able to essentially kind of
triangulate exactly where that noise is
coming from how far away it is and how
far down it is all of those directional
signals then combine in the owls medulla
to form one big three-dimensional image
of exactly where the sound is coming
from and what's around it without ever
using the eyes
they're seen you know with their ears
one study even found that some owls can
determine the direction and distance of
some small prey in just one 100th of a
second
that's 10 times faster than one flap of
a hummingbird's wing
look into an owl's eyes and what do you
uh see are supposedly wise right the
wise old owl and they are associated
with the goddess athena and who is also
the goddess of wisdom
so the question is how smart are owls
and the answer is not terribly smart
they have a very small brain compared to
the size of their body
but the thing is they don't have to be
smart
because they're very good at what they
do
so maybe those eyes aren't so wise but
when it comes to spotting prey they're
more advanced than ours
if we see in standard depth they see an
imax
some owl's eyes make up 30 of the weight
of their entire head
human eyes
just one percent
that gives them more room for muscles
inside their eyes which allows for
faster focusing and a higher kill rate
[Music]
but that's not the only way their eyes
have ours beat they also seem much
better in the dark and one of the
reasons why is because their eyes are
shaped very differently than our own
[Music]
can you guess what unusual shape the
eyes of owls most resemble is it a a
pear
b an oval or c a dumbbell
plus could an owl ever pick up a person
i mean it would be a predator of humans
most definitely
in 2012 a blind screech owl was rescued
in california and when it opened its
eyes rescuers saw what looked like the
starry night sky looking back at them
but even less celestial owls have pretty
unusual eyes
before the break we asked you to guess
what unique shape the owl's eyes most
resemble
is it a a pair
b
an oval or c
a dumbbell
the answer
[Applause]
you know when we look at an owl's eye
all we're seeing is just the very
surface of it and they're round
but actually when you take them out
they're more pear-shaped
the owl's eye falls aren't round at all
but while this might seem odd to us
ball-eyed traditionalists
it actually helps the owl hunt prey in
near total darkness
here's how it works
the back of your eye is like a movie
screen the bigger the screen the more
light you take in
and the better you can see in the dark
the owl screens are huge and it's all
because of that unusual pear
shape they get larger as they go back
into the skull creating the larger
retinal area
so on owls it's receiving more light and
images
with its giant screens the owl can see
up to 100 times better in the dark than
we can
maybe even better than any animal on
earth
definitely better than a mouse
the killing fields of some owls can be
up to two square miles or 1280 acres
in some fields there can be as many as
200 mice hiding out in any one acre
that's
000 mice per owl
[Music]
a lot to keep track of but to ensure no
delicious morsel sneaks away behind the
owl's back it has yet another secret
weapon
the owl has eyes in the back of its head
okay maybe not literally
but with its famously flexible neck it
can seem like it
dramatic turning of the head is a very
characteristic feature of owls
and now can rotate his head 280 degrees
they also can flip their head backwards
and turn it upside down
[Music]
that's bad news for mice in all
directions
the question is how can anything have
such a killer range of neck motion
without killing itself
[Music]
first the owl has 14 vertebrae in its
neck two times more than even the
tallest giraffe
that long spine gives them a more
flexible range of movement than most
mammals
[Music]
if a human tried to rotate his head 280
degrees he'd pinch the arteries in his
neck and it would be lights out
[Music]
but unlike us owls have extra wide
canals in their vertebrae up to 10 times
wider than the artery itself
so when they rotate their neck it gives
more room for the circulatory system
going to to the brain
and just in case the blood flow is cut
off owls have special pools of blood at
the base of their skulls it's like their
brains have their own backup generators
there was once an ancient barn owl that
stood five feet tall and had a 12-foot
wingspan its name was tito gigantia
did it be a little scary to see if i put
out um
that would be quite a predator it would
be a predator of humans most definitely
have something of that size but modern
owls are still plenty deadly and if
there's any doubt
witness the talents that automatically
crush bones on impact
the feet of an owl are remarkably
powerful
unlike other birds that typically have
three toes forward and one toe back owls
have two toes forward and two toes back
and that gives them a larger surface
area and more pressure per square inch
to be able to capture their prey
as for how the owl lands those talons
with such precision
the owl can actually hang and pivot in
the air like a gymnast on the rings
this silent hang time allows the owl to
position its feet just right and from
there
most mice are dead before they even know
what hit them
after the hunt it's time to eat but some
prey can be hard to swallow
[Music]
the owls have two stomachs the second
stomach is more like a garbage compactor
it squeezes out all the soft tissue and
all that's left in there is the hair and
the feathers and the bones of what the
owl has eaten whatever's left comes up
the way it went down the only evidence
this perfect predator was ever here
[Music]
their roars can be heard by other lions
from more than 30 miles away
but if there's any weakness in that roar
they're dead
when they're trying to kill they can
leap farther than four smart cars lined
up end to end
and when it comes to mating the darker
the main the more tail you get
all this and it's also grossed 6.2
billion dollars on broadway
it's the lion
next
the cheetah it can go from zero to sixty
two times faster than a porsche 944
turbo and yes no one calls the cheetah
king
the tiger the biggest of all the cats
with the strength to single-handedly
take down a 2 000 pound buffalo but no
one calls him the king either
even the jaguar
with a bite strong enough to pierce a
bowling ball
has never been elevated to the regal
status of king
there is only one cat with the power and
presence to earn that title
this is
the lion the true king of cats
but if it's not the fastest or the
strongest what is it that makes the lion
so king worthy
[Music]
to find out we're about to explore all
the ways the lion beats the rest to gain
its royal status
and the coronation begins with the one
thing lions have above all other cats
their own crown behold the lion's mane
the true dark-haired maine lions
are these males that are in peak prime
of their life and have never lost a
fight
those are the ones that the females just
think are irresistible which i think is
great
the darker the mane the more
testosterone in the mail it's like an
advertisement for the ladies
[Applause]
once a male has lost a fight truly lost
a fight probably due to stress he loses
most of his mane
and then the mane grows back later
so the females can actually tell if the
male has ever lost a battle just by the
color of his mane
and since they don't want any weaklings
fathering their cubs this is one case
where blondes don't have more fun
for the next three to four days the lion
and his queens will mate every 12 to 15
minutes over 40 times a day
[Music]
it's estimated that for every cub that
lives to be one year old the male and
female will have made it 3 000 times
[Music]
it's good to be the king
[Music]
from the ancient cave lions of europe to
the american lion which at 1100 pounds
was the biggest cat to ever live
these kings were at one time the most
widely distributed felines on earth more
than any other mammal except humans
today the lion fights for territory just
as fiercely as any other cat but unlike
say the cheetah
this king builds its castle walls with a
roar as loud as a plane's engine
it's 25 times louder than a lawn mower
can last up to a minute long and can be
heard by humans from five miles away
that's nearly a mile longer than the
entire vegas strip
and there's a reason that roar has such
resonance
unlike humans the lion can raise and
lower its voice box like a trombone
slide the lower the larynx
the deeper the roar
[Applause]
[Music]
and new research shows the roars
actually coming out in three-dimensional
surround sound like a dome around his
kingdom
[Music]
everywhere is just completely engulfed
in this
[Music]
marvel of noise
depending on the positioning of the
lion's larynx and the frequency of its
roar
other lions may be able to tell
everything from a challenger's age
health and even its ability to defend
itself
[Music]
even more amazing that message may have
a wider reach than we previously thought
some of the new research done in
northern namibia along the skeleton
coast there were two gps callers on
adult male territorial lions and one
lion roared
and another lion was over 35 miles away
and as soon as that lion roared
the other lion perked its head up and
just made a beeline towards that lion
and then they proceeded to have this
tremendous fight
so not only did the second lion hear the
sound of the first lions roar from 35
miles away
but was also able to detect some
weakened frequency in the original lions
roar to let him know he could take him
that lion ultimately ended up winning
that fight
tigers have certainly seen their fair
share of the spotlight but of all the
animals in the wild the lion seems to be
the one most represented in pop culture
google lions and movies and you'll get
over 53 million results
tigers a measly 35 million
so maybe one reason the lion is
considered the king is because he's got
a good pr team
for over 90 years mgm has been using the
lion to open most of its movies
what some consider to be the first known
programmable computer in the world
dating back over 500 years was leonardo
da vinci's robot of a lion
over 40 sports teams on six continents
have named their teams after the lion
the stage show of the lion king has to
date made over 6.2 billion dollars the
highest gross of any work in any media
in entertainment history
[Music]
as fierce as the king of beasts can be
there's a surprisingly small animal in
africa that has been known to pose a
big-time threat to lion kind
is it a the baboon tarantula
b
porcupines or c the army ant
[Music]
plus better killing through cuddling
[Music]
don't look now but there's a line
looking down on you
up in the night sky next to the big
dipper you'll find leo one of the most
recognized constellations first
identified as far back as 4000 bc
no other cat except the lynx has its own
constellation so even back then we knew
the lion was king
but even kings have to wash their backs
and sometimes threats come from the most
surprising places before the break we
asked you which small animal can pose a
big threat to lions
is it a the baboon tarantula
b porcupines or c the army ant
point of fact the answer is be the
porcupine
sometimes curious lions will try to make
porcupines a meal
and quills can get stuck in their jaws
so that porcupine quilt kind of festers
often gets infected leads to this
debilitating injury
with their jaws injured they don't have
the strength to bite into normal prey
many of the
animals that actually become
man-eaters have porky pineapples in them
so they go after this really slow
bipedal animal you know humans if
there's nothing else around then then
we'll do
of all 36 species of felines on earth
lions are the only true social cats and
it's not just because they like each
other's company
for african lions the number one cause
of death is other
a male alliance
needs to have a lot of friends if it's
going to defend its territory against
other males
to stay on his throne the king must also
be a politician cementing its social
bonds
and the way they do that according to
some research is what i like to call
tactical cuddling
lions will rub their heads against other
lions heads and they'll also lick each
other and this isn't just because it
feels good
it's actually appears to be more like
the way grooming in primates works which
is that these interactions are meant to
create and maintain
social relationships
[Music]
and that's what really sets the lion
apart from all other cats it's also what
makes the king one of the most
successful predators in the world
all cats hunt
but with the force of the pride the lion
has a distinct advantage they can
coordinate their attacks
in most cases the king hangs back to
protect the territory
while his queens do most of the work
there are the ambush hunters that are
laying there waiting
and then as soon as the prey gets close
the lion reaches a top speed of 50 miles
per hour twice the speed of a cyclist in
the tour de france yet still 10 miles
per hour slower than the fastest cheetah
[Music]
but the lion has both speed and synergy
[Music]
the hunters can use their tails as turn
signals a twist to the right and the
whole pride
pivots and here's something else you
won't see in most cats
so lions have very distinctive roles
often in hunts and usually that same
lion will have that same position every
single time they're hunting
it's similar to like rugby players
and so you'll have the wings and these
are the runners they initiate the
attacks and they'll run that prey into
the center in the center those are the
animals that will grapple and
physically attack the prey
then when the time is right
the center line pounces
at full speed it leaps up to 12 feet
high four feet taller than the tallest
man who's ever lived
that jump can span a distance of 36 feet
the length of four smart cars end to end
finally the claws come out a 400 pound
female flying through the air top speed
of 50 miles per hour can hit with more
force than a car crash
prey caught this furry missile's
trajectory don't stand a chance
with a measured fight force of around
2000 newtons it's still weaker than a
tiger
but the solo hunting tiger only has one
mouth the lion has a whole pride's worth
[Music]
so what really sets the lion apart
[Music]
strategy coordination
and above all else
numbers
that's what makes it the king of the
jungle
except there's just one thing
lions don't live in jungles i mean
really the king of the jungle is the
tigers
i don't know where that that phrase came
from
i guess if you have a pride of 20 lions
i mean you can do anything you want
[Music]
you